oh
It's Been Said time and time again
Morning Routines are Very important Whether it's our parents telling Us how Vital a Hearty Breakfast is or
Various online articles That Talk about The best Morning Routines
The idea that efficiency is Crucial When we Start our day Is a Much echoed one
The Real question though is whether or not there is any scientific evidence to back These claims
What's happening to our brains When we first Wake up how does that Affect our Morning Routines
These questions Will Be Answered in this detailed video
It is genetic
It's important to understand That Morning Routines are often Out of our control
How well many Psychologists share The Theory That Genetics determine whether you're a Morning person or a Night owl
That means that no amount of
Organization planning or getting Up Early Is going to make Your morning Routines easier to Handle if you're a Night owl
so Instead of fighting against Your genetics you Should Be Working with them
Till Rona Berg Who wrote a book on the subject Called internal time Chrono Types social Jetlag and Why you're so tired
Shares This premise he and other Psychological
writers Have popularized the belief That each person is better at Certain Tasks at different Times of the day and
So it's up to you to learn about Yourself and organize youR day accordingly
The Night Before
Your morning Routines Should Start The night before
This is especially true if you know that you're more effective in the evening as Opposed to the morning although It can Be used to
Your advantage even if you're a Morning person
If
You don't function well in the mornings you can Save Yourself a Lot of stress and more Importantly time By setting Things Up the night
Before
This could include setting Out Your outfit for the day
Packing Your Lunch or making sure you have everything you Need in your bag ready to go
You Should also Allow Yourself to relax in the evenings don't Work Until the moment you decide to go to Sleep
Leaving some relaxation time before Bed will leave you Feeling more Well-rested allowing You to function Better in the morning
Consider Setting a Regular Bedtime for Yourself Too a
Study Published By Cardiff University in 2017 Showed That sleeping at The same Timing tonight Reduces stress in teens
choose Your meal Carefully
Your parents were right about One Thing
Breakfast Is the most important meal of The day
Having a Good breakfast in the morning Will not Only aid Your body during the day but also your Mind
The American Journal of Clinical Nutrition Revealed The importance of Eggs in a Good diet
They Studied more Than
1,400 men and women and those Who consumed choline Which is Vitamin B and Eggs performed Better in memory and verbal Tests
Blueberries are another Great option for a strong Breakfast as our Almonds
The American Journal of Epidemiology
Released a Study That Shows that Vitamin e Which almonds have in abundance Can Help With Reducing cognitive decline
especially With Elderly People
European Journal of Nutrition also Released a Study That Showed That men and Women who ate
Almonds Early in The day were less Likely to Feel Hungry Later in the day Meaning Almonds are Excellent as Satisfying your appetite
Get Your Stressful tasks done in the Morning
There are Actually three different Types of People When it comes to their preference for the time of day the
first Is the Standard Type
People Who Work equally well during the night and the morning and have no preference for When they Work and function well
These People's Circadian Rhythms are normal
The Second Type the so called Morning person
Functions well in the Morning and They fit in perfectly with the typical workday of 9:00 to 5:00
The Last Type are the night owls Who function best at night
Meaning They're fighting a constant Battle against Society's norm of getting Up Early and finishing Work before the evening
These People are more Likely to develop stress and emotional Instability
The Only Type of Job That Would Lead to less stress for a Night owl is one that Involves starting Work late and Working even
Later The so called Graveyard Shift
despite all these differences these distinct personalities might Have more in common Than previously Thought a
German Study done by The
University of Würzburg Showed That Although Night owls had poorer Sleep quality and were Generally less Healthy Both Night owl
And Morning People Could Not Handle Stress Very Well in the evening and we're much Better Equipped to deal with it in the morning so
Whether you're a Morning person a night owl or anything in Between
Try to Get your stressful tasks done during the Morning
According to studies This Will be a lot easier Than trying to do it at Night
Be creative in the Morning
Recent Studies Have Called into question the logic of Rushing and being As efficient as possible During our Morning Routines
These studies Have Shown That organizing Your Mornings down to the most minut details can Actually be detrimental to your creativity in
The Psychological Journal Thinking and Reasoning
Researchers Marie Keith and rose Axe presented evidence That Creative Thoughts are most Likely to recur When we're groggy
Unfocused and tired in
Other Words You're most Likely to come up with the new ideas when you first Wake up
Maybe We Should Stop putting so much focus on waking Ourselves Up in the morning maybe We Should Stop placing so much Emphasis on increasing
Our focus Levels right After We Wake Up by doing exercises and getting Ourselves
In the zone if you Really want to be creative in the morning
Take Your time and don't Be afraid to zone Out for a few Minutes
Meditation
Seriously consider Adding Meditation each Morning to your Early Morning routine if You want to help YouR functionality During The day
This Isn't Just a New age nonsense as the power of Meditation is backed Up by science
Many Studies Have Shown The incredible effect that Meditation can Have on the brain
One Study By William Marchant Was Released in 2014 Called Neural Mechanisms of Mindfulness and Meditation
The Study Showed That Meditation stimulated The medial Cortex Default mode Network insula
Amygdala Lateral Frontal regions and Basal Ganglia all Areas Involved with higher Brain Function
We hope You've Enjoyed the six pointers we've discussed to help You function at your best
So are you a Morning person or a night owl What Adjustments are going to make Your morning routine more productive for Your overall day
Share your views in the comments Section Below and don't forget to subscribe